a lot of people go you know what's it
like making a movie without Pablo
and that's not the right question what's
it like living without yeah yeah brother
you're not in it Vin Diesel Michelle
Rodriguez and more opened up about their
friend and former co-star Paul Walker
et's Kevin Frazier was with the cast on
the red carpet at the premiere of the
fate of the Furious which hits theaters
April 14th that about midday a movie I
would call him and I don't have that
call now and I don't have that person
that's dreaming up the impossible with
me we're constantly thinking about him
was he in your thoughts yeah of course I
think ultimately that's that's pretty
much the reason why this movie is darker
than the rest we didn't want to jump in
and pretend that everything's ok you
know after after such a big loss I think
that you have to kind of reinvent the
thing and go dark pitman out of it the
last movie was for Paul we love to say
that this movie is from Paul
so I mean his presence is always going
to be felt and at this point we're
working hard and trying to make the best
movie possible for him to continue on
his legacy I can do no replacing Paul
ever ever ever ever
[Music]